Hello.
Welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today, we're gonna take a look at a
project called Tetragon.
Tetragon is an EPBF based security and observability
tool with runtime enforcement.
Consumer policies written by you, Tetragon will run
across your fleet of infrastructure and assure that
your applications are behaving.
We'll be taking a look at a few
examples of what that actually means.
But, of course,
before we get into the really cool features
of Tetragon,
we need to get it running.
So in this quick video, let's take a
look and install on Tetragon
on to a Linux host.
Let's go.
So here we are on the Tetragon homepage.
First thing we're gonna do is go to
documentation.
From here, we're going to click on installation.
Now we should note there are multiple ways
to install Tetragon.
You can install Tetragon directly to the Linux
host, and it will run as a system
d service.
However, if you wish, you can deploy it
as a container or deploy it with a
Helm chart to Kubernetes. Now, of course, we're
gonna take a look at running Tetragon
with Kubernetes.
It is the best way to run it
because it hooks in to Kubernetes resource model
and allows you to configure Tetragon
with everyone's favorite programming language,
YAML, YAML, and more YAML.
Allowing us to use custom resource definitions to
configure Tetragon is just the easiest way when
you're shipping this stuff to production.
But if you just want to start playing
and exploring with Tetragon, installing it to a
Linux host is also just fine.
So let's get acquainted with Tetragon, and then
we'll take a look at the Kubernetes installation.
So from here, we can see that we
can grab Tetragon from the GitHub releases.
This is all pretty standard, pretty normal, no
surprises here.
Let's copy this command
and run.
We can then untar and
install
Child's play.
Now we can start
system t service.
I don't need sudo because,
hey, I'm Rawkode.
We can see that Tetragon is now running
on our host.
Awesome.
So now that Tetragon is running, let's see
it in action in its very simple form.
So let's run echo
wall
hello,
and we're gonna type this to at where
we do plus one minute.
This will run the wall command in exactly
one minute from now.
That gives us enough time to then use
the TetracylI
where we can run get events.
Get events is gonna show us all the
things that Tetragon is aware of in the
cluster
without any policies or configuration
at the moment.
And we can already see some processes running
in the background,
and there is our walk event.
And what we can see here is that
we got some JSON blobs here that tell
us that the wall command was executed with
the argument hello,
with the pit,
the shell,
times,
all the information that you need to understand
the processes on a Linux machine.
Now process management
or at least process visibility is something that
you get out of the box when you
are running Tetragon.
No matter what command I run on this
machine, we will see it in the get
events output.
Where Tetragon really shines is where we start
to enrich or add our own tracing policies,
hooking into the kernel and defining a set
of actions that should happen in response.
So let's take a quick look
at adding a tracing policy
that shows us whenever someone
is messing around with the modules loaded into
our Linux kernel.
So the first thing we're gonna do is
run tetra
tracing policy
list.
And you can see at the moment we
have no tracing policies added to Tetragon.
We can run that command again with add,
this time pointing it to our trace dot
YAML.
Now when we run the list, we can
see that we have something called monitor kernel
modules enabled true.
Now let's take a look at our trace
dot YAML.
We can see it looks like a Kubernetes
custom resource because it is a Kubernetes custom
resource. Even though we haven't deployed Tetragon to
Kubernetes yet, we're using the same configuration to
add our own tracing policies.
And here, we're specifically adding some k probes,
kernel probes,
to monitor for security
kernel events, such as module request,
read file, do in a module, and free
module.
Now there aren't any actions attached to this
policy yet, but what we will see is
that as we interact with kernel modules,
Tetragon will tell us everything that we need
to know.
So let's split this session in half
and SSH onto the machine.
On the top, we're going to run tetra
get
events.
This time we'll add the flag o compact
just so it doesn't take up as much
vertical real estate as we get more logs.
To confirm that this is still working, we'll
run l s and we see lots of
output.
So what about kernel modules?
Well, we can run l s mod,
and so far we're just seeing the processes
that we're running.
Well, let's run mod probe z f s.
And if we scroll up, of course, we
see the processes that were executed.
But we can also see after we executed
Modprobe ZFS,
we have all these syscalls that we asked
Tetragon to monitor.
Security kernel read fail, do in it module,
all the way down. The Modprobe handles dependencies
when you're loading a module onto the kernel.
So, of course, we're gonna see multiple modules
loaded before our Modprobe command exits with a
successful code of zero.
Neat. So we're not gonna take a look
at adding actions just yet. We're gonna dive
into that more as we explore process life
cycle and
file access in the next two videos. But
the takeaway so far is just that very
easy to get Tetragon running on a Linux
machine.
The Tetragon CLI allows you to add and
manage your tracing policies
as well as to get events to understand
what is happening within your system.
So I think it's about time we deployed
this to Kubernetes.
So to deploy on Kubernetes, we go back
to the documentation.
Now we're going to use Helm, so this
isn't anything you haven't seen before.
We add the repository,
do an update,
and ask it to install.
Can then run kubectl,
get pods all,
and we'll see that our Tetragon pods are
now spinning up. And this will just take
a moment. Now that it's running, we can
do a kubectl
by dash f using the same trace dot
YAML we used on the Linux machine.
From here, you can run get
tracing
policy
and dash o YAML
to confirm it's exact same module probe we
used earlier.
Awesome.
So that's installing and getting started with Tetragon.
There's a lot of really awesome features that
we're gonna dive into, so check out next
two videos as we explore how to build
automated actions and runtime enforcement,
file access,
and process life cycle across Kubernetes
and Linux.
We'll see you soon.